the Joe Rogan experience right but you
know what else is weird is that like the
same mentality that says this says that
a white kid who grows dreadlocks and
dresses in urban street wear is
culturally appropriating yes many many
of the people that would sing think that
yeah including there's a there was a
movement that they had a band I think
most people abandon it but it's really
ridiculous for a while where they were
yelling at white girls wearing hoop
earrings because they were saying that
this is a latina thing you're culturally
appropriate than that but it's not like
then if you historically you got to go
back to ancient Sumeria invented hoop
earrings mm-hmm so you are you from
Babylon hmm are you are you from
Mesopotamia no then shut the [ __ ] up
because you're culturally appropriating
if you do you have a Korean phone in
your hand yeah guess what that's
culturally appropriate those Italian
jeans culturally appropriate yeah who
made your sneakers huh China what the
[ __ ] are we talking about culturally
appropriating is one of the dumbest
[ __ ] things because that's what
cities are they're melting pots of
Awesome cultures and they all get
together just is if you're a [ __ ]
dude and you want to dress up like Bruce
Lee
that doesn't mean you're culturally
appropriate it means you're a Bruce Lee
fan and it's kind of cool you're
admiring that and so you're you're
trying to take it on it's all woke it's
all woke culture it's this culture of
compliance they want you to comply it's
all that's what it's about more than
anything it's getting people to change
getting people to listen to you and do
what you want them to do I want you to
stop wearing those [ __ ] earrings I
want you to stop wearing dreadlocks
meanwhile dreadlocks the Romans wore
[ __ ] dreadlocks dreadlocks are not
necessarily a black thing although most
black people like you if you do it's
more rather black people wearing them
than white people
but there's white people have had
dreadlocks forever so you can we've all
seen dirty hippies with dreadlocks
yeah I go to a [ __ ] Grateful Dead
concert it's a lot of dirty white people
with dreadlocks they're not trying to
culturally appropriate they're trying to
be dirty hippies with dreadlocks yeah
they're they exist they're real to say
that that's cultural appropriation it's
[ __ ] crazy
it's create you we all appropriate we
all do we all do is
you use if you are in the United States
in 2019 you're a part of the the
greatest melting pot the world has ever
known and to decide that you can have
some of that but you can't have other
parts like come on man stop good luck on
Halloween Jesus Christ I read this list
of things you shouldn't do on Halloween
it was like don't put a feather in your
head don't put don't even tattoo don't
put a tattoo of something that would
identify you as Native American or Asian
yeah I don't have Asian letters tattooed
that was a thing that people used to do
oh is that a thing you shouldn't do now
yeah you can't do that anymore
I never was a fan of that to begin with
Obama bro you didn't brought he meant
give a speech that's not excellent it
was great yeah yeah it was excellent
he's telling people like we're looking
to cancel people all the time the end
this is a perfect quote that he said the
world is messy and it is messy here's
what we got to stop looking for things
that make you angry and just try try to
let things go and just be nice to each
other well my heart and dialogue these
people want to just talk and have you
listen like I saw a woman coming out of
a [ __ ] restaurant the other day and I
was walking in and a t-shirt said I did
I don't want to hear her men stop
talking I don't want to hear from men
and it was like I'm sorry
did I do something to you have I have I
not raised a beautiful daughter and been
a loving husband and a great son to my
mother and a great friend to a lot of
women and men toward many female comics
that I bring on the road with me and
hired when I was a head writer on TV
shows that I'm hired and and it's like
don't [ __ ] put me in that category
how about we talk about do you have an
issue with with you know what's going on
with you personally with involving me
let's talk about as a human being one on
one as an individual but that's that's
the thing they're denying the individual
and they're making everything binary
it's you and them it's us and them it's
one and zero it's it's not if there's no
room for nuance
yeah there's no is no room for the
complexity that is the human race yeah
this idea like men should shut the [ __ ]
up
want to hear from white men that's
another one I've seen that shirt I don't
want to hear from ya that's it's all
nonsense it's it comes from people that
want compliance this is the the whole
thing about what culture is people that
felt like they've been pushed around
they felt like they've been bullied they
felt like they've been maligned they
haven't been treated fairly and now they
want to turn it on you and they don't
give a [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] of
you if you're white man I don't give a
[ __ ] what your opinion is shut your
[ __ ] mouth and they feel like they
can say that mmm because this culture
and bow and Boldin's people by letting
people get away with nonsense by letting
people say things like that like walking
away like if I was owned a restaurant
someone walked in with shirt like that
I'd be like get the [ __ ] out of here
just like if you walked into a shirt
with a shirt that said black people
should shut the [ __ ] up yeah get out man
get out get out you really think that
you have no room for black people
talking get I don't want you around your
mind is rotten you're thinking a
terrible way go cleanse yourself go yeah
go take a [ __ ] meditation class or
something figure out what's wrong with
you but don't don't bring that toxic
energy around people it's stupid
yes criminal Tory lets half the
population and it's like I understand
that women have been they've had a
different experience than men black
people have had a different experience
than white people these there's issues
that need to be addressed and corrected
and enlist me in that yes I'm perfectly
willing to don't force you right to
comply yeah
[Applause]